Oh my god, you're such a trad wife.
You're so demeaning on tik tok teaching women to be trad wives.
What is y'all's obsession with hating on trad wives?
Trad wife is just a buzz word for a traditional wife slash mom.
It kills me that this is even part of the debate on social media.
Am I a trad wife? My answer is absolutely yes,
I am. Do I cook and clean for my husband?
Heck yes. Do I make sure my face is done
by the time he comes home from a long day of work
so he has something pretty to look at?
Yes. Do I rub his feet when he spent nine days planting at the farm?
Yes. Do I try to prioritize his happiness when he's home from work?
Yes. Do I serve him in and out of the bedroom?
Yes. But see,
all y'all are looking at this like a sacrifice,
like I'm giving up my entire existence to serve this patriarchal man.
Let me tell you what I get in return.
Most importantly, I get the ability to stay home with my children
without having to clock in to an 8 to 5 at a corporate office
working for a man who doesn't give two craps about who I am
or my future or my family
or my well being.
I get a partner who equally puts me on a pedestal in different ways.
I get a roof over my head,
food to Feed both my children and my own belly.
And I get equity in our business.
Yeah, I'm not just out here working for a salary
for something that I could lose if they find out I'm not valuable
the next day. I am my husband's partner.
Not just ethically and morally and in his eyes,
in the laws eyes, but most importantly,
he treats me like a partner.
He comes home every day and tells me how important what I'm doing is.
He makes me feel valued.
He lets me know that he would not be able to do anything
that he is doing right now,
creating and growing our business,
if it was not for me taking on my gender roles.
Oh, gender roles.
Another buzz word. By taking care of our children that we both love,
taking care of our house, making sure that our home is a sanctuary.
And listen, I'm not just in charge of, like,
cooking and cleaning and other deeds, right?
What women do is create the culture of our family.
And the culture of those boys sleeping in their cribs right now.
Because what I do will teach them what to do with their wives
when they're older.
They will take on my traditions and what I value when they're older.
Yeah, it's indoctrination,
but they're not being indoctrinated by the government in school,
they're not in daycare. And all the sacrifices I do right now,
before the age of three, I do A lot of work, guys.
Everything we talk about here in attachment theory,
it's a lot of work. But guess what?
I am making sure I create the best foundation
so that they don't end up on our couch at the age of 35.
So that they can be successful and have a really good relationships
and merge into the world as they need to.
Because at the end of the day,
we're not of this world, but we are in it.
And they have to function as real men in this society.
Something I believe we truly lack nowadays
is really your selection of a man.
So I take what I do very seriously,
and you should, too, Mama.
Every decision you make, everything we do,
dictates the future. Not just of our family,
of our sons, of our daughters,
but of our nation.
But so many of us just sit here and complain about how bad men are.
So I'm not gonna sit here and complain.
Even when my husband drives me up the wall,
I'm gonna lift him up,
and I'm gonna make sure that my boys are lifted up,
and they are the princes of the next generation.
So, yeah,
I take what I do seriously as a trad wife or a trad mom.
Because at the end of the day,
I dictate that next generation.
I am the king, creator.
So I'm not up here crapping on women.
I'm here to tell you that your Job is freaking important.
And so all this discourse talking about, oh,
Chad wives, and it's so patriarchal B S.
Our job is so freaking valuable.
So, yeah,
I am a Chad wife, and I take it seriously.
And I'm honored to be a mother of those two boys.
And I am honored to be a wife to my badass man.
That is my rant on tried wives.
Thanks for coming to my TikTok.